[Music]
on this Friday night China suspected spy
in the sky what's been lurking over
Canadian and American airspace we know
that it's a surveillance balloon what
China is calling the device the warnings
to Canadian Pilots the reassurances to
people on the ground and what this means
for diplomatic relationships with
Beijing
avian flu fears it's a very severe
infection with a very high mortality
rate concerns about how contagious this
virus is among animals and the anxiety
it could spread to humans
and surviving a boat capsizing how these
fishermen fought to stay afloat
global national
for a Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us we
begin tonight with a story that sounds
like it came straight out of a spy movie
The Pentagon is tracking a Chinese
surveillance balloon hovering over the
United States right now we also know it
flew through Canadian airspace and
Global News has learned Pilots were
warned by air traffic controllers to be
on the lookout for an untethered balloon
here's what else we know
right now is over the center of the
continental U.S and it's moving East the
balloon is massive roughly the size of
three school buses and it appears to be
carrying solar panels and satellite
technology and it's flying high 60 000
feet above the ground that's well above
any commercial air traffic we're
tracking the story from several angles
for you tonight but let's start with
Jackson prosco on how the U.S is
responding this thing is up in the sky
and I have no idea what it is it first
appeared as a gleaming orb over Montana
it's been there stationary for about the
last 35 minutes unusual in its movements
inexplicable to Witnesses on the ground
at first I thought it was a star but I
thought that was kind of crazy because
it was broad daylight it is in fact a
high altitude Chinese balloon the size
of three school buses the Pentagon calls
its presence a clear violation of U.S
sovereignty with one clear purpose
Espionage we know that it's a
surveillance balloon and I'm not going
to be able to be more specific than that
we assess that there is no threat a
physical threat or military threat to
people on the ground the U.S has been
tracking the balloon for days and
swiftly communicated its displeasure to
China in protest Secretary of State
Anthony blinken postponed a planned
visit to Beijing China's decision to fly
a surveillance balloon over the
continental United States is both
unacceptable and irresponsible China
then issued a rare statement of regret
claiming the balloon is a civilian
Airship used for meteorological research
that simply blew off course the balloon
is maneuverable clearly it's in it's
violated U.S airspace but what to do
about it the Pentagon Wade shooting it
down as it flew over Montana given its
size that was deemed too risky to people
on the ground it's now drifting slowly
across the continental United States and
will for days the surveillance balloon
is uh believed to be loitering longer
than previous surveillance balloons that
the Chinese have sent over it's not
clear what intelligence China may be
hoping to gather or what message it may
be trying to send in Montana the balloon
hovered near a sensitive U.S military
base home to dozens of nuclear-tipped
intercontinental ballistic missiles
what's more the Pentagon won't say
exactly where the balloon is or where it
may may be headed at a time of rising
tensions with China the U.S does not
believe this was an innocent mistake in
fact the Pentagon confirms there have
been past incidents involving Chinese
balloons over American airspace the
exact details of those remain classified
Farah
Jackson Brosco in Washington thank you
Jackson tensions between Canada and
China are also Rising with the balloon
again it's been confirmed to have been
in Canadian airspace this week so let's
bring in our chief political
correspondent David Aiken now David
what's been ottawa's response well far
the Canadian government's reaction to
this Chinese balloon largely mirrored
the reaction by the Americas there was a
diplomatic response we're monitoring it
very closely the minister insisted that
the Chinese Ambassador be called in to
explain the situation from their point
of view and we will continue to stand up
for Canadians rights all the time and
like the American Military there was no
direct Canadian military response the
Department of National Defense or DND
confirmed that the Chinese balloon did
indeed travel through Canadian airspace
though again like the Americans Canadian
military officials refused to provide
the details about the route that the
balloon took but DND did say Canadians
are safe safe and Canada is taking steps
to ensure the security of its airspace
including the monitoring of a potential
second incident and then we'll get right
to your questions U.S military officials
for what it's worth said they were not
aware of a second balloon incident at
this time Canadian officials would not
answer any further questions the whole
matter though has set back China's
relations with both the U.S and Canada
it's outrageous it's very concerning
that a hostile foreign government had a
spy balloon in our airspace and then
that continued to Transit into the
Northwestern United States
we as Canadians should never tolerate
Espionage by Foreign regimes and we
should work with our partners in the
United States to hold the regime in
Beijing accountable and in fact Canadian
and American authorities are doing just
that military and intelligence agencies
from both countries say they are taking
all necessary measures to safeguard
Continental security Farah
David Aiken in Ottawa thank you David
now these types of balloons are not new
in fact similar tactics have been used
for Espionage since the early days of
the Cold War so that leads to another
question why would Beijing use
old-fashioned technology like this
balloon in the age of sophisticated
satellites Eric Sorensen explores that
angle for us tonight
it's a distinctly different tone from
the Chinese regretful almost contrite
about its balloon over American airspace
is a responsible country that abides by
International laws said the foreign
Ministry spokesperson it has no
intention of violating the airspace of
any sovereign country but Chinese
intentions are very much in question for
a balloon the U.S says didn't arrive by
accident
I am trying to verify the situation she
said and speculation and hype will not
help resolve the issue
just weeks ago a Chinese fighter jet
flew within meters of a U.S aircraft
over the South China Sea no such
Contrition the timing of the balloon may
have been a blunder says one expert but
under Xi Jinping China is willing to
challenge America's power and Global
reach the launching of what may well be
a military will learn
shows that increasing capacity of China
across across the board to challenge the
West challenge the United States showing
the path for a balloon from China One
analyst using American government data
plotted the possible though unverified
route over Canada and remarkably right
over Montana the home of nuclear missile
silos and carrying on over the
continental United States balloons were
used in war for more than a hundred
years by combatants to gather
intelligence on the enemy but in the
space age for the last 60 years balloons
gave way to spy satellites but this
suggests a comeback for balloons and a
new technological advantage for China
given the fact that there are Advanced
anti-satellite capabilities having
another option in terms of a
balloon-based surveillance kit it makes
a certain amount of sense
the U.S angered the Chinese with their
own Navy fighter jets flying over the
South China Sea just last week an
incursion by a Chinese balloon in
American airspace only increases tension
and diminishes Trust on both sides I
think that tensions will be increased it
will be harder for the Biden
Administration to make concessions to
China to try and and Tamp down the
rising tensions the balloon is
geopolitically provocative and China had
to know it would be but for now Beijing
must wait the balloon is in American
airspace and the next move will come
from Washington Eric Sorensen Global
News
we turn now to travel from China and
covet 19. Canada is extending its
screening requirements for travelers
coming from there Hong Kong and Macau
the federal government will require
Travelers arriving from those
destinations to take a test before they
board their flights until at least April
5th the testing requirement came into
effect on January 5th it was set to
expire tomorrow but Ottawa says it's
still concerned about the lack of
pandemic data coming out of China
especially considering the country's
loosening of covid-19 restrictions
the drug maker behind the first Canadian
developed covid-19 vaccine is shutting
down operations
quebec-based medical is closing after
its only shareholder Mitsubishi chemical
group pulled investment in the company
586 jobs are affected manicago's coveted
vaccine was the first to be approved for
use by Health Canada the federal
government gave the company
173 million dollars to construct its
facility and for vaccine development the
shot was also the world's first
plant-based vaccine authorized for human
use but it was rejected by the World
Health Organization over the company's
ties to Tobacco giant Philip Morris
there are new concerns over a worldwide
spread of another virus that is the
avian flu
for more than a year there's been a
significant uptick in cases among wild
birds and farmed poultry and now is
Heather urac's West explains there's new
evidence that the illness is spreading
among other mammals too
for poultry Farms across Europe and
North America there are few words as
devastating as avian flu it's deadly
it's a the pathogenic forms of Avian
Influenza including h5n1
are it's it's a very severe infection
with a very high mortality rate the
Saving Grace has been that this virus
while deadly didn't spread easily Beyond
birds and while human cases are still
rare birds are no longer the only ones
getting sick and that experts say is a
growing source of alarm people are
concerned that the virus is the h5n1 or
the avian species of influenza is
becoming more transmissible much of this
concern stems from a recent Outbreak on
a mink farm in Northwestern Spain the
outbreak happened back in October but in
January genetic sequencing revealed
these animals had been infected with a
new strain of h5n1 one that seems to
allow avian flu to spread more easily
mammal to mammal so the way influenza
works is like covid it continues to
change but it has a unique mechanism
where if two different flus infect the
same animal at the same time they can
actually mix their genetic material and
a brand new flu emerges it's why the
scientific Community is watching the
virus closely and calling for an
increase in surveillance of animal
health worldwide the concern is if it's
more easily transmitted between mammal
hosts could it be could it jump into
humans and could there be mutations that
facilitate transmission on the heels of
colvid that's not something anyone wants
to see the good news is work on
potential avian flu vaccines and
antivirals are already well underway so
that if this virus does change to become
a greater Global threat the world won't
be caught so unprepared Heather urich's
West Global News Calgary
millions of Canadians are bundling up
and hunkering down
coming up the warnings about frigid
winter conditions
if you're watching us from Eastern
Canada you're feeling it some of the
coldest air on Earth is gripping the
region
take a look at environment Canada's
weather alerts there are extreme cold
warnings covering nearly half of this
country record lows are expected in
several places today temperatures in
Toronto and Halifax could dip below -20
Ottawa and Montreal will be closer to
-30 with the wind chill and minus 43.
the powerful arctic front is stretching
to the core of the U.S as well the
National Weather Service there is
warning up once in a generation wind
chills
following months of outcry the liberal
government has withdrawn controversial
amendments to its new Firearms
legislation critics said the Amendments
unfairly Target rural Canadians by
Banning some popular rifles and shotguns
what we acknowledge today is the
insufficient consultation that more work
had to be done we are committed to not
affecting hunting and at the same time
taking the types of guns that are
capable of mass Carnage off the streets
originally designed to ban handguns bill
c21 was amended in November to include
shotguns and rifles that are popular
with Hunters farmers and Indigenous
peoples opposition leaders have called
the Liberals handling of the file of
failure and say they are prepared to
fight any future amendments that are
tabled
breaking news from Memphis Tennessee
where a sixth police officer has now
been fired in connection with a Tyree
Nichols case an internal police
investigation has found officer Preston
Hemphill violated multiple policies
including those related to personal
conduct and truthfulness as well as the
use of a stun gun Hemphill was involved
with a traffic stop that happened before
Nichols violent arrest on January 7th he
died three days later the five police
officers who brutally beat him have been
fired and charged with second-degree
murder two EMTs were also suspended
today for failing to render critical
care to Nichols
[Music]
more Russian sanctions ahead the latest
strategies Western countries are
employing to try to [__] Russia
another town in eastern Ukraine took a
direct hit from the Russians today
shelling severely damaged this popular
Market in the Russian occupy dunesque
region residents spent the day sifting
through the debris to salvage anything
they could
today Canada announced it's sanctioning
another 38 people and 16 entities linked
to Russian disinformation and propaganda
for President Putin's War the European
Union also says a new round of Russian
sanctions will be announced later this
month Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski met with top EU leaders in
Kiev today and as Redmond Shannon
reports he's once again pleading for
stronger weapons
good morning Dennis a trip to kiev's
main post office for European commission
president Ursula Von der Lyon there to
promote an eu-sponsored exchange scheme
for energy efficient light bulbs
Ukraine's power grid continues to
struggle under regular Russian shelling
meeting President Vladimir zielinski
wonderlion says the eu's 10th round of
Russian sanctions will be announced in
three weeks to coincide with the
one-year anniversary of the full-scale
invasion the plan is to focus once more
foreign
on technology
that can and should not be used by
Russia's War Machine
in particular to close loopholes and
stop components and weapons being sent
to Russia from countries like Iran
zielinski again asked for more powerful
weapons on Friday Washington announced
its latest arms package for Kiev
including rockets that can reach much
further into russian-controlled
territory in Ukraine but on future EU
membership some less encouraging words
for zielinski they are no rigid
timelines
but there are goals that you have to
reach reforms for example
most notably tackling corruption
zelenski recently fired several top
officials following corruption
allegations Ukraine is one of eight
candidate countries waiting to join the
block
meanwhile the three Baltic EU leaders
whose country's all border Russia have
increased calls for a ban on any Russian
or Belarusian athletes competing at next
year's Paris Olympics so uh boycotting
is is a Next Step Poland Sports Minister
says he wants Canada and other Western
Nations to threaten a coordinated
boycott unless the international Olympic
Committee puts a ban in place
Redmond Shannon Global News London
and Global News will Air a special on
February 25th to mark one year since the
latest Russian invasion of Ukraine
said Sudan is also ravaged by War and
instability and today Pope Francis
arrived there for the final leg of his
trip to Africa
[Applause]
thousands line the streets to welcome
the pontef who waved from his car window
the pope was also joined For the First
Time by his Anglican and Scottish
Presbyterian counterparts the three
leaders represent the main religions in
South Sudan which is predominantly
Christian Francis urged leaders to end
the violence ethnic hatred and
Corruption that have been plaguing the
world's youngest country
the pope will celebrate Mass on Sunday
before flying home to Rome
planetary defense program next NASA's
plan and case a massive asteroid were to
head toward Earth
[Music]
talk about keeping your cool during a
crisis new video shows three fishermen
stranded at Sea after their boat
capsized off the western coast of
Australia now they had life vests but
something else helped keep them afloat
in the Rough Waters a cooler they clung
tube sort of a makeshift raft
all three men were eventually rescued
thanks to an emergency Beacon and one
was treated for hypothermia
now eons ago when the dinosaurs were
wiped out by a massive asteroid some
people asked could it happen again NASA
is taking that threat seriously so much
so it's been working on a planetary
defense program and recently took a big
step toward a protection plan that now
seems a whole lot more realistic
Global's soul and go reports
as many as 6 000 meteors enter Earth's
atmosphere every year most cause little
damage but the concern is that one day a
big one could head our way and the
consequences would be dire that's why
NASA intentionally crashed a spacecraft
into an asteroid in September it's part
of a mission called Dart the double
asteroid redirection test it's a
terribly exciting that we've taken this
first step in what's called planetary
defense send a spacecraft with a body
that's about the size of a vending
machine and slam it into dimorphos which
is about the size of a small football
field and knock it off course something
that's never been done before the goal
of Dart was definitely all about
asteroid deflection not asteroid
destruction the idea is that this small
nudge would add up to a bigger change in
its position with time armed with a
camera the spacecraft provided NASA
Mission Control real-time images as it
moved into place for impact
it successfully collided with an
asteroid on September 26 2022 becoming
Humanity's first demonstration of
asteroid deflection since that Collision
they have been analyzing data from the
mission it turns out the dart spacecraft
did a better job than anticipated it
significantly changed the asteroids
orbit
all of it would not be possible without
what we are learning from the meteorites
that land here on Earth
and some of that comes from Canadian
scientists like University of Alberta
Professor Chris heard his research in
turn is used by NASA because knowing
what materials are in meteorites helps
with future asteroid moving missions
that really does buy us time and and
understand for when there might be
something even larger that is
potentially hazardous and NASA will
continue to analyze data from the dart
Mission over the next few months to
determine if this is a reliable option
for planetary defense from asteroids
pharah
seal and go with Edmonton thank you for
that and you can learn more about the
work to stop an asteroid from destroying
our planet on the new reality Saturday
at 7 right here on global and that's
global national for this Friday I'm
Farah Nasser on behalf of our whole crew
here I want to thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your Canada is Ottawa where
things are actually too cold for the
annual winter festival there the city
canceled all of the outdoor activities
for winterlude today as a deep freeze
settles in over Eastern Canada stay warm
up there until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
foreign
[Music]
thank you